-Welcome back, everybody!
I'm hanging out with Rose Byrne!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We know you're from Australia.
You do a lot
to promote tourism there,
so I thought it'd be fun to play
a fun Australian-themed new game
called "Down Under
Drawing Challenge."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Down Under
Drawing Challenge ♪
-Now, we have a stack of
Australian-inspired clues, okay?
You and I are gonna take turns
picking a clue,
drawing it on this tablet.
But since it's the
"Down Under Drawing Challenge,"
you draw the clue,
and it'll be shown upside-down
on the screen behind us.
Once, you start drawing,
the other person has 25 seconds
to guess the clue, okay?
Rose, since you're my guest,
why don't you draw first?
-Okay.
-Yeah, you're so lucky.
Yeah, here we go.
All right.
-So you can't look at this.
-No, I won't look at this.
You pick the clue, and I have
25 seconds to guess it.
-Okay.
-All right.
So just draw it normal, I guess,
and I'll just --
-Okay.
-Let's start the clock.
Go.
♪♪
Hand.
A ring.
Uh...
[ Laughter ]
Oh, crocodile!
-Yes!
-Is that right?
[ Dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I cheated a little bit,
but it's right.
Very well done.
-Oh, it's upside down.
-Upside down
it even looked good.
Even upside down I loved it.
-Okay.
-All right, here we go.
I'm gonna clear this one.
-Aww, croc.
-Well done, well done.
Okay.
-Okay.
-Here we go --
-So, now I look here?
-Yeah, or you can
look back here.
It doesn't matter.
Okay, here we go.
Okay.
♪♪
-Mm.
Well, I don't know
what that looks like, but...
[ Laughter ]
Oh, it's a person.
Upside-down person
in a pond...
[ Laughter ]
...with a -- with a tree
over the top of them...
[ Laughter ]
...and they --
Yeah, it's a tree.
It's a tree.
Oh, it's a wave!
They're surfing.
-Yes, it is! Yes!
[ Dings ]
-Yes, yes, yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Both laugh ]
-I keep forgetting
it's upside down behind me.
I'm like, "How are you
not getting this?
Yeah, but...
"It's clearly --" Okay.
All right, this is yours.
Yeah.
Here we go, bud.
-Okay.
-I'm not looking,
but then I'll look.
-Okay.
All right.
-Yep.
-Okay.
-25, go.
♪♪
Nothing. Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Hair.
Hairpiece.
Oh, it's upside down.
Flames.
Bonfire.
Uh, uh...
It's water again?
The Loch Ness Monster?
-No.
-A boat.
-No!
-No. I know, but upsi--
Teeth?
Oh, wait. The sun.
Oh, it's mountains.
A wave?
-No!
-A storm.
-No.
-It's lightning.
It's a -- no.
[ Buzzer ]
-That's a really bad drawing.
-Oh, is that the Opera House?
-Yeah.
-That was very hard.
How would I -- Of course,
Australian-themed clues.
-No, that's not your fault.
-No, that's fantastic!
-No, I bombed that.
-Audience says yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I forgot --
I forgot it was Aus--
-It looks like a --
-No, you were fantastic.
That was actually awesome.
I was looking at it
upside down, as well, so...
All right. Here we go.
-Sorry.
-Australian-themed clues.
Here we go.
-Okay.
-What?
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
-Nothing.
Oh.
A fish.
-Mm-hmm.
-A fish.
Fishy.
Fishy and a blobby blob blob.
[ Laughter ]
Uh, um...
Birds, birds, birds, birds.
Coral reef.
-Yes!
Yay!
[ Dings ]
Coral reef?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not bad.
I'm proud of my --
-That was really hard.
-That's not bad.
That's pretty good. That's
a good coral reef, friend.
-This last one here, bud.
I'm gonna give you one, as well.
-Okay.
We'll both draw
at the same time, okay?
And we're gonna see
if we can get Questlove
to guess what we're drawing.
Okay, bud?
-Okay.
-Ready?
-Me and you will draw
the same thing.
-Oh.
-I know.
It's kind of...
-All right.
Okay, okay.
-Oh, my God.
Are we doing this together?
-Yeah, that's me.
-Is that Harbor Bridge?
-Oh, my God.
Bondi Beach?
-No.
-Wait.
Is this upside down?
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
-I thought we were
drawing it separately.
-That's not a knife.
[ Laughter ]
-No, it's not that --
[ Buzzer ]
Oh, my God!
Were we even close?
[ Laughter ]
How about look at it right-side
up and see what it is.
-Shrimp --
-Yeah.
-Is that shrimp on the barbie?
-Yes!
[ Dings ]
-Whoa!
-That is shrimp on a barbie!
♪♪
Nice!
Shrimp on the barbie!
Rose Byrne, everybody!
-Oh, my God.
Hey, if you're planning
your next vacation,
be sure to check out
Australia.com.
We love Australia.
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show."
Stick around.